♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
After victories in Nevada
and Arizona over the weekend,
Democrats are projected
to maintain control
of the Senate.
But it's worth noting -- barely.
Democrats are in control
of the Senate
the way your grandma is
in control of her Chrysler.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah,
she has the steering wheel,
but I still don't feel
totally safe.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
has announced
that he plans tomorrow to make
a "very big announcement."
That's right --
He's very excited to announce
that the 2024 election
has already
been stolen from him.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] It's very unfair,
what the future holds.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Yep, former President Trump
is reportedly set to announce
his third run for president,
though, at this point,
the hats are becoming untenable.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's 80th birthday
is this weekend.
He'll celebrate it the same way
he does every year --
until 7:00 p.m.
"All right, that's enough.
Time for bed, folks."
According to a new poll,
voters would prefer
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
to be the Republican
presidential nominee in 2024,
over former President Trump.
I can only assume it was
because they weren't given
a third choice.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
daughter Tiffany got married
on Saturday, and not,
as I thought,
from the looks of that archway,
on Easter.
[ Laughter ]
What'd you do at the reception,
hunt for eggs?
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump gave
a toast over the weekend
at his daughter Tiffany's
wedding and said,
"Have a great life together."
Well, that's very nice,
but after last week,
we all know what a Trump
endorsement is worth.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump attended
his daughter Tiffany's wedding
over the weekend
and danced with her
to "Here Comes the Sun."
Wow!
Usually in that family,
"Here comes the son"
is a warning.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
authorities in New York
arrested a mother last month
after she allegedly allowed
her 10-year-old son
to get a tattoo.
Worse, the tattoo was
to celebrate
one year without a cigarette.
[ Laughter ]
You'll think about it on the way
home and like it more.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden met in Bali
yesterday
with Chinese president
Xi Jinping.
It was the second most awkward
meeting of the week.
[ As Trump ] And you say
you're a daughter of mine?
That's great. Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] President Biden
reportedly told
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
last week
that he hopes
she remains in office.
He then waited 40 seconds
for her to say it back.
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Secretary of State
and Democratic gubernatorial
candidate Katie Hobbs
is projected to defeat
Republican Kari Lake.
Apparently, voters didn't think
Lake was a real Arizonan
because nowhere in the state
is it that foggy.
[ Laughter ]
More than a year after his
apartment and office were raided
by the FBI, federal prosecutors
announced yesterday
that Rudy Giuliani will not face
criminal charges.
And I'll bet he's relieved,
because he's really been
sweating it
for the last 20 years.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
today released his memoir
titled "So Help Me God,"
which is just what he says
whenever he sees a woman
wearing slacks.
[ Laughter ]
ABC News aired an hour-long
sit-down interview last night
with former Vice President
Mike Pence.
So, if you've ever wondered
what an hour-long interview
with Mike Pence is like,
watch a five-minute one.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC last week named several
states in its worst category
for flu levels, including
Alabama, Georgia,
Mississippi, North Carolina,
Tennessee, and South Carolina.
Basically, if your college
football team is any good,
get your flu shot.
[ Laughter ]
An Illinois couple
recently got married
in the aisle
of an Aldi grocery store,
and then they splurged
on the honeymoon.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Former president Trump
officially launched
his 2024 presidential campaign
last night
from the ballroom
of his Mar-a-Lago Club.
Though it's hard to take a
campaign announcement seriously
when you don't even
leave the house to do it.
"I will lead America
to greatness again!
All right, I think I'm gonna go
up and read for a while.
Can you guys keep it down?"
Former president Trump
officially announced last night
that he will run for president
in 2024.
I mean, okay,
but if you're gonna do it,
we're going back
to the 2016 jokes.
It's gonna be tiny hands,
bad hair stuff.
We're gonna mix it
with "Hamilton"
and the lady Ghostbusters.
The jokes are gonna be so hacky,
you'll think Hillary
wrote the monologue.
-Pokémon Go to the polls.
-You'll wish
they were that good.
[ Light laughter ]
When asked by a reporter
yesterday if he had any reaction
to former president Trump
announcing his 2024 campaign,
President Biden said,
"Not really."
Can't blame him.
It's still two years away.
That's like someone asking you
if you're excited
for "Avatar 3."
I don't know, man.
Gonna see how "2" looks,
I guess.
During his speech last night,
former president Trump bragged
about his close relationship
with North Korean dictator
Kim Jong-un.
Replied Kim Jong-un,
"No, no, no, don't endorse me.
I...
saw what happened
in the midterms."
NBC News has projected
that Republicans
will take control of
the House of Representatives,
thankfully,
this time the legal way.
[ Light laughter ]
Former president Trump's
daughter Ivanka
issued a statement last night
that she will not
be participating
in his 2024 campaign.
Said Jared, "Can you sign that
from both of us?"
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Coors Light
yesterday launched
a color-changing nail polish
that can be used
to help customers decide
when their beer
is cold enough to drink.
Or if you're out of nail polish,
try touching the can.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have released
the first trailer
for the third
"Magic Mike" movie.
The news first --
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
The news first reported
in a truly garbled text
from your mom.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was actor
Pete Davidson's 29th birthday.
And if you're --
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
Let me see if I can figure out
the connective tissue.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Today was actor Pete Davidson's
29th birthday.
And if you're wondering what to
get him, nothing, he's fine.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
The White House
is reportedly planning
to present President Biden
with a birthday cake on Saturday
at his granddaughter's wedding.
And if you're wondering
how old he is,
he'll be at his
granddaughter's wedding.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
will celebrate
his 80th birthday on Sunday,
while Fox News will celebrate it
all year long, baby!
[ Laughter ]
In a speech today
from the House floor,
Speaker Nancy Pelosi announced
she will not seek another term
as Democratic leader,
but will remain in Congress
to finish her term.
Meanwhile in the Senate,
his eternal curse
remains unbroken.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate yesterday
passed a bill
to expand medical marijuana
research by unanimous consent.
They also decided,
by an 85-15 vote,
that "unanimous"
is a funny word.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mouths words ]
Former White House
Chief of Staff
Mick Mulvaney
said in a new interview
that he thinks
former President Trump
is "the only Republican who
can lose in the 2024 election."
"Hold my beer,"
said Herschel Walker
to a mailbox.
[ Laughter ]
During a campaign stop
yesterday in Georgia,
Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
spent more than two minutes
trying to recount
plot details from
an untitled vampire movie.
Said Walker,
"Oh, it's not a movie."
[ Laughter ]
Tell him, mailbox.
At the same stop, Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker
talked about werewolves
and vampires and said,
"I don't want to be
a vampire anymore.
I want to be a werewolf."
Well, one thing's for certain --
He definitely doesn't
want to be a senator.
[ Laughter ]
Fans of the singer Morrissey
are upset
after he recently
ended his concert abruptly
after just 30 minutes
without any warning.
Fortunately, if there's
one thing Morrissey fans love,
it's when Morrissey
makes them upset.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm zinging a couple
of old high school girlfriends
with that one.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Japan had
to remove a 90-inch jump rope --
removed from his bladder
after he shoved the rope
into his penis.
On the bright side, he finally
got those kids off his lawn.
Did we have to show the X-ray?
A jump rope.
Microsoft yesterday added
a collection of classic games
to its Teams platform,
including solitaire.
Yeah, 'cause what says "teams"
more than solitaire?
The point is, you do it alone.
Did you also add "Cranking It"?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, we're doing the -- We're
doing that jump-rope-penis bit.
What's a good palate cleanser?
Let's use an early '90s slang
for masturbation.
That also reminds me of those
Morrissey fans.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida scientist recently
found an entire alligator
inside a Burmese python.
It's what -- It is -- Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
This is -- And I feel bad
because this is
maybe the tightest of
all the jokes.
This is maybe
the most tightly written,
and that's why I'm gonna
take it back,
because, you know,
credit where credit's due.
Just try to think of anything
else to clear your mind.
Maybe the jump-rope penis.
A Florida scientist recently
found an entire alligator
inside a Burmese python.
It's what's called
a Florida turducken.
Pretty good joke.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We couldn't get the X-ray
of what that would look like?